é sustentabilidade e economia são coisas
tão intrinsecamente relacionadas à
economia reflete o nosso modus operandi
reflete nosso modelo de vida o que a
gente faz espera anseia etc
isso nos leva a ser ou não sustentáveis
é e quais são os fatos que eu gostaria
de apresentá-los são indicadores de
limites planetários
com isso os novos indicadores estão ali
e chegar à conclusão que em quatro deles
nós já atingimos limites bem superiores
aos níveis de risco aceitáveis que são
eles os ciclos biogeoquímicos a a
biodiversidade mudanças de uso e
cobertura da terra e por fim mudanças
climáticas são esses quatro vejo todos
entrelaçados com as mudanças climáticas
surgem como efeito das mudanças do uso
da terra que tem como um norte por
exemplo a expansão da agricultura sobre
padrões convencionais bem diferente da
agricultura de são josé é que é muito
mais sustentável é sustentável de fato
dessa agricultura que exige uma
quantidade muito grande no 3 exógenos
até a precisa processar o extra
inclusive do petróleo para lançar mão
ela quebra o ciclo de biogeoquímica a
gente está expandindo esse é o talvez o
principal problema que a gente tem hoje
é ecológico foi criada na década de 90
para tentar representar o indicador de
quanto a gente impacto do planeta
enquanto o planeta tem capacidade de
resistir e chegou à conclusão que desde
a década de 70 nós já utilizamos mais do
que um planeta terra das nossas
atividades
ou seja o que pode isso a gente utiliza
mais do que uma mãe só tem uma coisa que
é isso a gente está avançando exatamente
na sustentabilidade
rita avançando exatamente a nossa
capacidade de manter essa possibilidade
de
usufruto da terra nas gerações
posteriores à é tem jeito tem saída tem
solução mesmo o mesmo a mesma
metodologia pegada ecológica que aponta
esses problemas
ela nos disse que se eu reduzir por
exemplo emissões e 30 por cento do co2
a gente tem condições de reduzir essa
pegada chegar por exemplo a uma vez e
meia uma terra e meia é sustentável não
absolutamente
mas indica que é um caminho que pode
reduzir essa pressão sobre o planeta é
esse esse gráfico interessante porque
mostra já um reflexo desses nossas
projeções para nós brasil
isso aqui é um resultado de
precipitações chuva no futuro 2070 até
2100 ou seja daqui a 80 a 100 anos
ele projeta um cenário mais otimista
para boa parte do país
toda toda a área acima de são paulo ou
incluindo são paulo uma redução e ter me
torno de 10 a 15 a 25% de precipitação
redução chuva o que significa isso
significa que esses eventos extremos de
secas que a gente vivenciou no ano
passado e no retrasado vão tender a se
multiplicar a a adotar uma frente um
padrão de freqüência muito mais
contundente e que por exemplo atividades
econômicas como nossa geração de
eletricidade é hoje 70% de origem
hídrica
isso afeta todo o nosso modo modo vivem
nove vende então pego dois duas
variantes do modelo que dá uma projeção
mais pessimista uma queda mais otimista
eu digo pra sociedade é assim que talvez
se comporte o clima no futuro o que
vocês querem fazer a sociedade toma
decisão essa é mais ou menos a um
raciocínio lógico se traduz a partir de
uma pesquisa científica como essa porque
nós hoje vivenciamos uma era que alguns
pesquisadores têm apontado como sendo a
ela entrou
ou seja a nossa pegada era do homem na
terra hoje
segundo esses pesquisadores ela tem a
capacidade de mudar a jesus fera como
tempo geológico no passado por isso a
criação de uma nova era
ontem mitos por trás disso né
a nossa forma de lidar com recursos
naturais etc
o primeiro mito é um mito da
superpopulação
então isso começou lá com thomas malthus
na inglaterra 19 já saiba que a
superpopulação e crescimento da
população uma taxa maior que a produção
poderia levar um do colapso
bom isso é foi foi retomado na década de
70 e 60 têm uma certa é rasca uma lógica
racional por trás disso mas a gente foi
a população hoje ela está entrando no
mundo ela está entrando numa fase de
estabilização das taxas de crescimento
então talvez a população não seja mais
esse grande problema mas talvez seja a
forma como a população atual lida com o
meio ambiente com recursos naturais etc
que seja o problema
bom aí vem um mito da finitude da
infinitude mito é esse é um mito que
está inserido no âmbito da economia
clássica da economia que a gente
vivencia quando o economista vai falar
no noticiário que é os recursos naturais
são infinitos a água infinita petróleo
infinito não vai acabar
e se por acaso acabar atender a acabar
ela vai aumentar tanto o preço aí
diminui a pressão e não acaba
infinito e por fim um mito da tecnologia
é o tech mix é muito comum ouvir dos
meus colegas ouvir da comunidade
associada à engenharia e tecnologia
resolve tudo
qualquer problema ambiental gerado hoje
pode ser re tecnológicamente resolvido
no futuro
de certa forma é uma certa verdade nisso
o problema é o seguinte nós perder a
resiliência ecológica antes que a
tecnologia resolva e ao perder lá eu
perco minhas funções
temos perco meu serviço perca água
queremos chegar até lá bom uma das
causas a que atribui essas esse nosso
problema ambiental global
a supervalorização do indivíduo e do
consumo
duas duas origens né uma vez certa forma
do liberalismo e outra do capitalismo
industrial ea sua máquina de mover o
mundo a partir do consumo
junto a isso aí talvez e eu entendo como
uma boa raiz da nossa degradação
ambiental atual a junção desses dois
fenômenos é é um economista famoso
joseph stiglitz e em 2001 foi nobel da
economia em 2001 postou essa frase é que
nós o que a gente mede é definir o que a
gente faz a gente mede mal a gente faz
coisa errada é literalmente a isso o
crescimento econômico é hoje a gente
fala em crescimento crescimento
crescimento
quando a gente fala de 6 stream é de
pessoas que estão na liderança da
definição econômica do mundo sempre fala
em consumo e aumento do pib o pib é o
nosso referencial
infelizmente a nossa final inclusive de
desenvolvimento ea pergunta que se faz é
as nossas medidas são certas pensando
que o stiglitz propôs seu bem
alguns exemplos são reduzir o consumo de
cigarro reduz o pib vai reduzir a
indústria bélica reduz o pib ou seja vou
de crescer
só que o decreto mesmo seu reduzindo-se
a bélica
a gente vai começar a mexer com esses
valores a entender um pouco mais que
está por trás disso será que realmente a
gente vai crescer
então toda se crise econômica podem
pegar mais a visão dos economistas
ministro em qualquer saída da crise
econômica
respondam consumo consumo
isso nos coloca essa questão do do
sindicato diz que a gente usa para dizer
se vale a pena ou investir
isso ou aquilo vem de uma deturpação de
valores também induz coloca valores
completamente deturpadas então voltar os
mitos
temos os dois mitos um mito do futebol o
mito da canoagem se bem mais recentes
muitos nem conheciam ele antes das
olimpíadas
neymar recebe em torno de 7 milhões e
quinhentos mil reais por mês salário
atual dele e o isaquias queiroz aqui um
vale menos que o outro
nós atribuímos de alguma forma esses
valores distorcidos gente eles são
objeto do que a gente atribui por isso a
gente tem que pensar quando pensa em
sustentabilidade é necessário não
suficiente é necessário mudar a
atribuição de valores e já encaminhando
para propor o final da apresentação para
onde vamos
isso aqui é um mapa da região nós
fizemos uma pesquisa recente pegando
aqueles dados e projeções do ipcc e
analisamos qual quais são as os as
vulnerabilidades do litoral norte e
termos de mudanças climáticas e levando
a elevação do nível do mar e outras
outras variadas
essas áreas em vermelho e amarelo são
áreas de de média e alta vulnerabilidade
são áreas que eu deveria olhar para elas
muito cuidado olha olha para um
legislador ou por um governo deveria
dizer olha cuidado com essas áreas não
as ocupe inadvertidamente que elas podem
ser elas são vulneráveis e podem estar
em risco no futuro
no entanto o que vocês estão vendo está
projetada em cima do mapa do zoneamento
ecológico do estado
a prioridade dado que se propõe o
zoneamento ecológico do estado estão
vendo vocês podem ver que ele essas
áreas estão em áreas que provê é prevê
expansão da atividade econômica
nós não estamos olhando enquanto
sociedade para essa vulnerabilidade
aqui em caraguá é um caso até pior é uma
área muito mais contigo e problemática e
nós estamos aceitando isso que a gente
pode com essas saídas quanto enquanto
sociedade
ou nós aceitamos esse caos
alguns acham que não isso vai
equilibrar a gente sabe disso ou que a
gente pode fazer é bom se eu tivesse a
resposta certa eu estaria vendendo ela
um preço bastante alto
é mas eu diria que a resposta certa de
certa forma já vem sendo usada desde as
13 50
nesse auditório é a resposta certa do
doutor do senhor josé é que pra mim é um
doutor honoris causa é a resposta certa
da do guilherme a resposta certa de
diversas pessoas que passaram por aqui e
apontar caminhos e soluções é é sairmos
do global para o local e começaram a
repensar nosso sistema de valores
eu diria como sugestão reduzir consumo
quebrar mitos pensar a gente tem deixado
de pensar na sociedade atual
cada vez mais mudar valores participar
efetivamente participar quando a gente
não participa tomam decisão por nós e é
exatamente o que está acontecendo em
relação a mudanças climáticas em relação
à degradação do planeta é pra finalizar
eu diria que sustentabilidade implica em
uma mudança da sociedade do ter para a
sociedade do ser
sem isso nós não seremos sustentáveis